- I just want to let everyone know
that I hope you're having
a great night tonight.
(crowd cheering)
Yes, but please try
not to step out of line
or I will not hesitate to put
you in a bare naked choke.
(playful music)
Hi there, I'm Aria and we're here
at the incredible Austin
Powers-themed bar,
the Electric Pussycat,
where I'll be working as
a bouncer for the night.
(sighing)
This will make sense in a moment.
I know you're probably
wondering about the gi.
- [Robert] Yeah, what
is going on with that?
- You got ruffians out there,
they want to shake down the establishment,
extort, whatever these hooligans do
but then they see someone
decked out like this.
I mean, what would you
do if you saw someone
watching the place--
- I'd possibly think twice
or say what's he got?
It's not Halloween is it?
(laughing)
It is security so you wanna make sure
that people are having a good time
but in a fashionable manner.
You don't want any hooligans
or you know, some knuckleheads
getting out of line
but at the same time,
you gotta realize that you
wanna have a good time,
we've all been out but
keeping it reasonable.
- I've never really been a big clubgoer,
so tonight, I'm looking forward
to getting a fresh
perspective on night life
from the other side of the ropes.
But unfortunately, as much
as Robert admires my gi,
it doesn't quite fit
with their dress code.
So, I have to quickly pop
next door for an outfit change
with one minor adjustment.
If things get rowdy, what's like protocol?
- So, if you're being destructive
to property, you know,
and being belligerent and
being too intoxicated,
those are signs that
you're immediately out.
You know, whereas you're
bumping into the chairs
that you'll see later on upstairs, okay,
that will get a warning,
but if they're like,
"Okay, well, (beep) you", you
know then, okay, you gotta go.
- Yeah, bare naked choke time.
- Yeah, yeah.
Possibly, possibly.
- Yes, absolutely.
- If they swing at you
then I would say yeah.
(playful music)
- I've been training
like all week for this.
- Look at that, look at that.
- Okay.
- Look at that.
- [Ashton] Just for tonight, huh?
- Yeah, look at that.
- Alright, look at you.
- Oh, oh, a fist.
(both exclaiming)
- [Ashton] There it is.
- That's a coworker.
- There it is. (chuckling)
- But soon after my shift starts,
I suddenly get my first
taste of the dangers
I'm facing tonight.
(suspenseful sounds)
This one lady tried sneaking in.
The moment Ashton was
like, "Oh, she's going."
It's like time stood still and I was just,
Hey, ma'am!
Ma'am, you need to get back here!
Please, Please.
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- We need you out here, please, please.
- I have my I.D.
- Oh! (exhaling)
- I thought you guys
knew who I was.
- Oh, we, oh (groaning and exclaiming)
It's scary to think that if she'd got in
and let's say, you know, she
like assaulted someone, y'kno?
Who's responsible?
Me!
Me.
But luckily, as the night goes
on, I begin to find my groove
(playful sounds)
Wow, that's a great I.D photo.
Do you have like a headshot photographer
you can recommend?
Oh, never mind.
How you doing?
Having a good night?
You know what would make
it even more fun, though?
Is if we had some methamphetamines.
- Aha!
Unfortunately, that's not my game.
- Oh, you don't have any on you?
- Nah, nah.
- No, no heroin?
- Nothing. (chuckling)
- Good.
- I'm sorry, sorry.
- Whoa, whoa, he's trying to sneak on by.
- [Man] Watch out.
- Aha.
- [Man] Watch out, Eric's coming through.
- Oh man, I got some photos
that I need to show you.
Maybe you'll think twice.
You know what, we should
get those photos--
- I don't think you need to do anything--
- I think we get--
- With those photos.
- I think we do, I think we
get those photos blown up
and we just like put
them against the wall.
I'm running out of battery, you know?
Like constantly having to
show people the photos.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, that's gotta be rough.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna take you in right now.
We're about to do a sweep of the club.
Austin and the go-go dancers
just hit the stage right now.
So, we wanna make sure that
they're able to do their thing
and not being interrupted
by any of the guests
trying to go on stage.
Nobody's throwing money,
trying to be obnoxious either,
'cause that does happen sometimes.
And then we're gonna go up
to the VIP area, take a look,
make sure it's not overcrowded.
We're gonna be able to guide the line,
making sure our cocktail servers
are able to get to our clients
to be able to get their drinks
as efficiently as possible.
The things that I mentioned
earlier, I want you to go ahead
and be on the lookout for them.
And if you need to take
action, you can take action.
- Do you like put someone
in a bare naked choke
if they do anything wrong?
- You're so into that bare naked choke!
- Hey, let's settle down
here, you guys are having fun
but let's play it safe.
- We want you guys to have a good time
but we can only have one person per booth
and please try not to swing, okay?
- But even though we were luckily
able to avert that crisis,
on our sweep, our cameras
captured a suspicious-looking man
who was now on my radar.
But not wanting to burden Robert,
I decide to launch my
own covert investigation.
And to help me on this task, I
quickly call in Petey Plastic
an actor I once hired off of Craigslist.
Have you ever hooked up
with anyone at the club?
- Oh, many times and in
(chuckling) stage rooms, bathrooms.
(laughing)
- So, I saw someone upstairs
that was acting, you know,
a little suspicious, a little
borderline belligerent.
Unfortunately, he saw me
so I can't do an undercover operation
but I'd love for you to
maybe look into this for me.
And if things get out of hand,
I'll be there, don't worry.
- Typical night out, I got this.
- We could be saving lives here.
(suspenseful music)
With the clock racing against us,
Petey begins his hunt for this delinquent.
We need to act fast because
who knows where he might be
and when he might decide to cause a scene.
But finally, Petey spots him and moves in.
- He is not trying to attack anybody
so we're all safe and good.
- Are you sure?
Did you look him in the eyes?
- I looked him dead in
the eyes and saw him
and it's just perfectly fine.
(sighing)
- Close call.
Thankfully, it looks like we have
the situation under control
and as relief washes over me,
I'm able to enjoy the rest of the night,
completing my duties.
How do you feel the security
at the bar is so far?
- The security at the
bar is fantastic so far.
- How would you say I've been doing?
- You've been doing a great goddamn job.
- I took these photos for you, Robert.
- Oh, is that right?
- And in fact, as the
night comes to a close,
I'm genuinely disappointed
that the evening has gone by so quickly.
Thank you so much.
- Well, thank you very much.
- Oh!
- I appreciate it.
Overall, I would say good job
because you follow direction
and you listened and you
knew what to look for,
that's why you were able to find
some of the things that
we had mentioned earlier.
You're very enthusiastic
and people respond to that.
- Is there any chance I
can keep this flashlight?
- Absolutely, it's all yours.
(laughing)
There you go.
- I'm so happy right now.
- So from Electric Pussycat,
(mic thudding) Robert
- And Aria.
Bye-bye.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday ♪
Dear David S. Morell
(laughing)
- Perfect, You got it!
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪